die nachrichten des tages
mit christian sievers einen guten
freitagabend ihnen allen geben sie uns
20 minuten für diesen nachrichten
überblick und kristin hat den sport
nachher in der sendung sehr emotional
und wir beginnen mit der aufarbeitung
der verheerenden flutkatastrophe im
westen deutschlands die jetzt die justiz
auf den plan ruft
die warnungen vor der flut und die frage
was schieflief jetzt ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft gegen den landrat des
kreises ahrweiler es brennt es qualmt
und die gefahr steigt waldbrände
erreichen die vororte von athen wind und
hitze fachten die feuer immer wieder an
herget und geht und geht 50 kilometer
lang jonathan hilberth holt völlig
überraschend silber und kann es danach
kaum fassen
[Musik]
es hätten sich zweifel ergeben ob es
sich bei dieser flutkatastrophe um ein
nicht abwendbar receive saal gehandelt
habe so sagt dass heute der ermittelnde
staatsanwalt
es geht um 142 tote allein in rheinland
pfalz und die frage wären opfer
vermeidbar gewesen
die staatsanwaltschaft koblenz hat
ermittlungen gegen den landrat des
landkreises ahrweiler aufgenommen es ist
erst mal nur ein anfangsverdacht unter
anderem auf fahrlässige tötung durch
unterlassen
darauf weisen die ermittler besonders
hin es gilt die unschuldsvermutung julia
schröter
die flutkatastrophe im aartal mit vielen
toten nun ein fall für die justiz
im fokus der ermittlungen der landrat
jürgen pföhler
es besteht der anfangsverdacht der
fahrlässigen tötung und fahrlässigen
körperverletzung durch unterlassen
auch gegen ein mitglied des krisenstabs
wird ermittelt wir sehen bereits jetzt
zureichende tatsächliche anhaltspunkte
dafür dass warnungen verspätet und
möglicherweise unzureichend waren und
auch evakuierungen möglicherweise zu
spät und wiederum möglicherweise
unzureichend angeordnet waren
das landesamt für umwelt rheinland-pfalz
hatte schon früh gewarnt bereits am
spätnachmittag mit der höchsten klasse
die prognostizierten pegelstände der a
ließen schlimmes erahnen
sie waren deutlich höher als alles
bisher dagewesene
trotzdem erfolgte die ausrufung des
katastrophenfalls und damit die
teilevakuierung erst kurz nach 23 uhr
landrat pföhler sieht sich dafür
strafrechtlich nicht in der
verantwortung
laut staatsanwaltschaft ist er
kooperativ teilte jedoch mit dass er die
einsatzleitung in der relevanten zeit
delegiert hatte die ministerpräsidentin
will die ermittlungen nicht kommentieren
nur so viel dass eine solche katastrophe
natürlich nicht einfach so vorbei geht
und wir mit dem wiederaufbau damit alles
erledigt haben sondern das
selbstverständlich alles überprüft
werden muss an welchen stellen ist es
gut oder vielleicht auch nicht gut genug
gelaufen das ist doch selbstverständlich
im aartal heute gemischte gefühle
ich finde das absolut richtig dass gegen
ihn ein ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet
wird
absolut wahrscheinlich nicht viel sagen
weil man die umstellung erkennen wer
daran beteiligt war
die flut werde kommen
keine frage aber man hätte schon leben
retten können
auch gut drei wochen nach der flut nacht
bleiben viele fragen offen
die ermittlungen werden zeit brauchen
sagt die staatsanwaltschaft
jetzt ist ganz klar ermittlungen sind
noch kein urteil sondern geld hat ist
bei uns unsere korrespondentin für
rheinland pfalz zu seiner guten abend
welches neue licht werfen denn jetzt
diese ermittlungen der
staatsanwaltschaft auf die stunden der
katastrophe also wenn man den
ausführungen des oberstaatsanwaltes
gelauscht hat dann ist dieser tag schon
ein wendepunkt bisher wurde immer betont
und man ging auch davon aus dass diese
flut plötzlich über alle gekommen ist
und genau das war eben nicht der fall
darauf hat der oberstaatsanwalt
hingewiesen und das ist auch ein
wichtiger grund die ermittlungen
überhaupt einzuleiten
aus dem rekonstruktionen der
staatsanwaltschaft ergibt sich nämlich
das der anfang der flut in schuld schon
am 14 07 um 17 uhr nachmittags war also
erst am nächsten tag am morgen des
nächsten tages um 2 uhr 30 haben die
fluten dann sind sich kurz vor der
einmündung erreicht und dazwischen lagen
mehr als neun stunden
und genau diesen sehr langen zeitraum
möchte die staatsanwaltschaft jetzt
überprüfen sie möchte genau ermitteln
was ist genau wann passiert hat es einen
zeitpunkt iks gegeben an dem man hätte
anders agieren müssen und wie hat der
krisenstab agiert hat er nicht früh
genug gewarnt
susanne vielen dank für diese
erläuterung heute abend ja die menschen
im katastrophengebiet brauchen weiter
hilfe 77 millionen euro haben die zdf
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer bereits
gespendet auf dieses konto vom
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser weitere
informationen im netz und im zdf text
unser nächstes thema heute abend ein
noch nie dagewesener zustand so
beschreibt der griechische
regierungschef kyriakos mitsotakis die
situation in seinem land
dichter rauch starker wind und immer
neue brandherde
das ist eine verheerende mischung
schauen wir uns das mal auf der karte
genauer an wird auf dem balkan die
flammen teilweise eingedämmt werden
konnten lodern die feuer in griechenland
und in der türkei mit voller wucht
weiter vor allem in der türkischen
küsten region bodrum
aber auch auf dem griechischen
peloponnes und nördlich von athen sind
die brände außer kontrolle ralf
schipanski berichtet es ist da mitten in
der nacht das feuer hat sich herr
aufgefressen ins dorf die einen geben
den kampf verloren die anderen wehren
sich mit dem was sie haben
weglaufen und dann wohin ich soll mein
haus abbrennen lassen wären wir gegangen
hätten wir alles verloren
wie es aussieht wenn das feuer gewinnt
offenbart sich nicht weiter von an
diesem morgen das tigers im westen des
peloponnes die farm verbrannt und mit
ihr ein großteil der schafherde wie ein
mahnmal der machtlosigkeit ragt das was
von der dorfkirche übrig ist über den
trümmern dieser existenz eine
katastrophe
das feuer kam mit wirbelwind die häuser
sind zerstört viele tiere kamen ums
leben
auch heute tun sich neue feuer auf wie
eine wand erheben sie sich nördlich von
athen
per sms wird jeder anwohner gewarnt
zusätzlich alt die polizei von haus zu
haus mal entlädt sich die wut alles
zurücklassen zu müssen mal die einsicht
bloß weg
die feuer werden auch für die
stromversorgung der metropole zum
problem
ganze stadtteile wurden notgedrungen vom
netz genommen regierungschef mitsotakis
warnt die bevölkerung hitze und dürre
haben das ganze land in ein pulverfass
verwandelt dramatisch ist die lage auch
in der türkei und die kritik wird lauter
dass die löschflugzeuge kaum
einsatzbereit sind
immerhin der außenminister verkündet es
kommt hilfe aus dem ausland holen chat
hubschrauber ebenso die usa um wie hier
bei bod um ein weiteres ausbreiten der
brandherde zu verhindern schlagen bagger
schneisen in den wald für viele zu spät
wir hatten eine woche voller angst und
panik letztendlich kann das feuer auch
zu uns wir haben unsere kinder geholt
und sind weggerannt
allein in der türkei haben die flammen
1000 quadratkilometer in schutt und
asche gelegt und es ist noch längst
nicht vorbei
wir gehen jetzt live in die
waldbrandgebiete und erst zu annette
hilsenbeck in der nähe von athen annette
guten namen hat man sich denn das jetzt
vorzustellen bei ihnen kann da quasi
überall mittlerweile ein feuer
ausbrechen
genau so ist das also das land ist
komplett ausgedacht und die windel sind
so unberechenbaren so stark dass sie
eben jenes kleine feuer als auch kleine
schwelbrände wieder anfachen wir sehen
das gerade hinter mir da war dieser
hügel denen wir da unten sehen
eigentlich schon ganz erloschen jetzt
auf einmal flammen die flammen wieder
hoch und auf der rückseite sieht man das
alles komplett in brand ist das ist
natürlich extrem schwierig für die
löschmannschaften also löschhubschrauber
und einsatzkräfte am boden sind
unermüdlich unterwegs
sobald die in feuer gelöscht haben ist
eben auch schon das nächste trend
nebenan was sich dann durch den wind
angefacht weiter ausbreitet man versucht
hauptsächlich die ortschaften zu
schützen aber sehr viele vororte hat man
jetzt trotzdem evakuiert und wie diese
messages die bienen bekommt diesen
nachrichten sagen eben auch mal wieder
an das jetzt erneut wieder eine
ortschaft evakuiert wird
und dann gehen wir über in die türkei
zurück war bot bei bodrum
wie sehr haben die feuerwehren die lage
dort unter kontrolle
also jedenfalls wesentlich besser als
noch bei beginn dieser feuerkatastrophe
vor einer woche wir waren heute in einem
gebiet hinter uns unterwegs etwa zehn
hektar groß und haben überall alle 23
kilometer sehr gut organisierte feuer
löschtrupps angetroffen
da sind teilweise berufsfeuerwehren aus
istanbul aus ist mir aus großen städten
zur hilfe geeilt außerdem muss man sagen
haben wir den ganzen tag hier flugzeuge
im einsatz gesehen spanische
löschflugzeuge russische helikopter aus
ist er aserbaidschan aber auch die
türkische verwaltung ist offenbar jetzt
aufgewacht wir haben gendarmerie
hubschrauber mit lösch wannen gesehen
auch hubschrauber vom forstministerium
da tut sich eine menge
trotzdem bleibt die gefahr der hügel
hinter mir brennt seit heute früh
man versucht das in den griff zu kriegen
aber entwarnung kann man im moment noch
nicht geben
ganz herzlichen dank in die türkei und
nach griechenland und damit zurück nach
deutschland und zum thema corona wo die
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidenten
anfang kommender woche mit der kanzlerin
beraten wie es im herbst und winter
weitergehen soll
ihnen macht die entwicklung sorge die
inzidenz ist auf niedrigem niveau aber
sie steigt stetig das robert koch
institut ruft alle nicht geimpften dazu
auf sich impfen zu lassen der korona
stand anfang august die aktuellen fakten
und zahlen hat thomas konsum dieser
sommer ist anders auch bei den
infektionszahlen vergangenes jahr stieg
die sieben tage incidents ab anfang juli
nur sehr leicht an
jetzt geht die kurve schneller und
steiler nach oben aktueller wert 20,4
ein grund laut lka die hochansteckende
delta variante ihr anteil in deutschland
nun 97 prozent die steigenden zahlen sie
führen bislang zu wenig mehr
krankenhauseinweisungen aber zu
problemen für die gesundheitsämter die
können infektionsketten oft nicht mehr
vollständig erfassen
klar ist nach wie vor infizieren sich
besonders 10 bis 39 jährige
betroffen ist aber zunehmend auch die
mittlere altersgruppe bei den über 55
jährigen ist die inzidenz einstellig die
tendenz aber steigend wer sich infiziert
war meist nicht geimpft sagt das rk ii
und auch das wer sich impfen lässt ist
zu fast 90 prozent geschützt
italien zieht im kampf gegen das corona
virus die zügel an seit heute braucht
jede und jeder ab 12 einen so genannten
grünen pass am eingang zu vielen
veranstaltungsorten oder den innenräumen
von restaurants schlange stehen vor den
vatikanischen museen nur mit
impfnachweis nachweis dass man genesen
ist oder einem höchstens 48 stunden
alten negativen test für geimpfte
urlauber aus deutschland reicht das
digitale eu im zertifikat wie es von
ärzten apotheken und impfzentren
ausgestellt wird und für deutsche
urlauber im süden von frankreich gelten
ab sonntag schärferer regeln die
südfranzösischen regionen ochs italien
und provence alpes côte d'azur sowie
korsika werden als hochrisiko gebiete
eingestuft bei der rückkehr müssen
ungeimpfte in quarantäne
kein risikogebiet mehr sind ab sonntag
die niederlande
dort sind die infektionszahlen
zurückgegangen
im dauerstreit über die
rechtsstaatlichkeit kommt polen der eu
einen schritt entgegen
brüssel hatte eine neu geschaffene
disziplinarkammer kritisiert und mit
strafen gedroht
jetzt hat das oberste polnische gericht
entschieden zumindest vorläufig keine
fälle mehr an die kammer zu geben
sie sollte eigentlich für
disziplinarverfahren gegen richter
zuständig sein und diese beispielsweise
auch suspendieren können
der europäische gerichtshof sah aber
unparteilichkeit und unabhängigkeit
nicht garantiert seit dem frühjahr
ziehen die internationalen truppen aus
afghanistan ab und es passiert genau das
was viele befürchtet haben die
radikalislamischen taliban nutzen die
gelegenheit und erobern sich stück für
stück gebiete zurück willkürlich töten
sie zivilisten lassen frauen
auspeitschen die nicht nach
ihrem weltbild leben die regierung
scheint machtlos auch in städten wie
kabel oder masar i scharif ist die angst
vor den taliban groß viele sehen jetzt
nur noch eine chance die flucht etwa
über die grenze zum iran katrin
eigendorf
sie wollen sich ein ticket sichern für
die busfahrt nach herat an der
iranischen grenze
es sind vor allem junge männer doch auch
familien wollen ins nachbarland iran
fliehen illegal familie hussein ii ist
vor sechs tagen hals über kopf aus masar
i scharif im norden geflüchtet
vorübergehend sind sie bei verwandten in
kabul untergekommen mit ihren drei
kindern wollen sie illegal über die
grenze in den iran
wenn die taliban zurückkommen ist unsere
familie bedroht sie werden mir meine
tochter wegnehmen oder meiner frau
gewalt antun
das ist das was ich fürchte so viele
tränen sind geflossen in den vergangenen
tagen vor allem die 14-jährige asma und
auch ihre brüder vermissen ihre freunde
ich habe alles aufgegeben denn ich denke
an die zukunft meiner drei kinder
zumindest kann ich sie lebend hier
wegbringen und vielleicht haben wir ein
besseres leben dort vier taschen packen
die who sah es am nächsten morgen ins
taxi alles was ihnen geblieben ist ein
paar kleider etwas proviant für die
reise ins ungewisse
menschenrechtler waren seit wochen und
berichten von gräueltaten die die
taliban an kindern und frauen verüben
in der provinz balkh haben sie ein
mädchen erschossen weil sie zu kurze
kleider trug sie haben eine schwangere
frau getötet angst verzweiflung und
trauer
die stimmung am busbahnhof im westen von
kabul
von hier aus wollen die fans einiges los
waren viele der busse sind alte
fahrzeuge aus europa 14 stunden dauert
die fahrt an die grenze wenn alles gut
läuft werden sie am nächsten morgen
schon im iran seien und noch dies zum
thema afghanistan die bundesregierung
hat nach zdf-informationen in der
vergangenen woche geheime gespräche mit
den taliban geführt dabei ging es um den
schutz von menschen die in afghanistan
für die deutschen truppen gearbeitet
haben in unserer zdf heute app finden
sie weitere informationen zu diesen
gesprächen und zu der frage ob solche
treffen überhaupt sinn machen so trennen
und ein skandal heute bei olympia schwer
erträgliche bilder bei modernen
fünfkampf aber christin du beginnst mit
erfreulich dass schöne zuerst große
überraschungen durch jonathan hilbert
800 kilometer nördlich von tokio
bündelte er in der schwüle von sapporo
überaus klug all seine kräfte und gewann
olympisches silber im 50 kilometer gehen
die erste deutsche wm-medaille seit 29
jahren
das ist ein besonderes kapitel in der
geschichte des gehens jonathan hilbert
hatte drei monate mit einer
schambeinentzündung zu kämpfen
zählte nicht zu den favoriten doch dann
gewinnt er nach einer taktisch
brillanten vorstellung silber wegweisend
die mentale unterstützung seiner
partnerin als es um die telefonate mit
seiner freundin anna geht packen hilbert
die emotionen jeden tag die fenster in
drei vier stunden
sie hat sich zeit für mich genommen und
hatte einfach gestaltet mir gut geht und
dass auch für dich an ihm fehlten 36
sekunden auf olympiasieger david
thomalla polen
dritter wurde der kanadier even dann
[Applaus]
fische silber auch für die deutschen
tischtennisspieler allerdings hatte das
trio um timo boll sogar mit gold
geliebäugelt doch wieder einmal
demonstrierten die chinesen ihre
unbändige stärker und gewannen souverän
mit etwas abstand überwiegt bei timo
boll patrick franziska und dimitrij
ovtcharov dann doch der stolze war eine
starke gesamtleistung und den gewinn der
silbermedaille
auch wenn china selbst im finale kein
einziges match abgegeben hat am
intensivsten schnuppert noch dimitrij
ovtcharov an einem sieg gegen den
weltranglisten ersten sendung geht er
sogar mit 2 1 sätzen in führung
hier
am ende wird es mit 223 die knappste der
drei deutschen niederlagen im endspiel
um gold unterm strich aber steht ein
glattes 13 0 für fast schon entnerven
überlegene chinesen wut und tränen sowie
jede menge kritik und entsetzen im
modernen fünfkampf der frauen es geht um
den harschen umgang von annika schleu
die auf goldkurs lag mit ihrem
zugelosten pferd das völlig verunsichert
nicht springen wollte
tränen der hilflosigkeit und angst in
diesem moment alles zu verlieren die in
führung liegende annika schleu auf dem
ihr zugeteilten fährt sant boi das schon
vorher den parcours verweigert hatte
auf die bundestrainerin kim raisner in
diesem moment verzweifelt eigentlich
sind wir deutschen im fünfkampf als gute
und solide und auch einfühlsame reiter
bekannt der teamarzt hat gesagt hat okay
also das war noch die letzte chance
irgendwie zu wechseln
dann hätten wir an der satz wehrte
nehmen konnten wir nicht also musste sie
mit dem pferd reiten es gibt keine regel
die pferd und reiterin hier hilft dr
dennis peiler vom fachverband für
pferdesport erklärt unser verständnis
der reiterei liegt nicht darin das pferd
als sportgerät zu betrachten
hier besteht bei modernen fünfkampf
offensichtlich dringender
handlungsbedarf
dieses drama endete für annika schleu
mit der disqualifikation im reiten
sie lag auf medaillenkurs und beendet
ihren fünfkampf nach dem laser run auf
platz 31 und ausführlicher blicken wir
auch darauf wieder im heute journal
ja das wird möglicherweise ja noch
folgen haben vielen dank kristin so
jetzt weit weg von olympia da sorgt
dieser herr für furore
das ist igor er ist russe 73 jahre jung
und guckt sehr lässig durch sankt
petersburg auf seinen parade sportgerät
einem ziemlich ramponierten skateboard
das pferd igor jetzt seit 40 jahren hält
fit und sieht auch beim absteigen noch
sehr elegant aus das wetter kommt nicht
zur ruhe starker regen und hagel mehr
gleich von westend tel
ich empfehle ihnen natürlich die
kollegin marietta slomka im heute
journal um 22 uhr heute
ab morgen freut sich an dieser stelle
jana pareigis auf sie ich sage danke
dass sie dabei waren und vom gesamten
team 19
in allem ein sehr angenehmer abend
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter ein altbekanntes bild in dieser
woche immer wieder tiefs über europa und
da nähert sich schon das nächste und
bringt kräftigen regen mit in die
alpenregion aber auch in den süden
deutschlands oder auch im norden wird es
schauer und gewitter geben mit dem
nächsten tiefs heranzieht
schauen wir auf die nacht und da werden
die schauer und gewitter im norden
allmählich weniger und ziehen nach
norden ab von westen her kommt neuer
regen auf ansonsten dazwischen trockenes
wetter die temperaturen bei zehn bis
zwölf grad im südosten 14 ganz im westen
und 15 in schleswig holstein
morgen am vormittag weitere schauer im
westen die sich allmählich entwickeln
und auch ganz im norden ist das der fall
ansonsten aber trockenes wetter und zum
nachmittag brodelt es richtig im norden
kräftige schauer und gewitter mit
starkregen und hagel im süden bevor der
dauerregen einsetzt noch heftige
gewitter auch mit größeren hagel möglich
bis 27 grad dort so ähnlich wie im osten
deutschlands und 19 grad richtung eifel
am sonntag dann weitere schauer und
gewitter im norden bis 24 grad und ab
montag zumindest im süden etwas ruhiger
und sonniger ein schöner abend